9 novembre 1989 les allemands de l'est
investissent le mur qui divisa berlin en
deux depuis presque trente ans il tombe
en quelques heures
pour des milliers de berlinois c'est un
moment historique
c'est enfin la liberté
cet événement est la conséquence d'une
série d'actions qui viennent de
s'enchaîner dans les pays du bloc
soviétique
au printemps les gardes-frontières
hongrois ont démonté le réseau de
barbelés qui sépare leur pays de
l'autriche
[Musique]
à l'été 600 allemands de l'est en
vacances en hongrie sont passés en
autriche
ils ont aussi été un millier à se
réfugier dans l'ambassade de la
république fédérale allemande altrad
à travers ces événements comment
expliquer la chute du mur de berlin
celle enquêtes que nous avons menées
que s'est il passé les services secrets
était-il au courant ont ils étaient
débordés ont ils laissé faire vingt ans
plus tard une question reste posée
quelle a été leur rôle
aujourd'hui ils rompent le silence et
pour la première fois les espions parle
moi
l'histoire commence à berlin en 1961
dans une europe coupée par le rideau de
fer depuis la fin de la seconde guerre
mondiale en rouge les pays communistes
satellites de l'urss un bleu les pays
dits capitaliste
l'allemagne responsable de la guerre
occupé par les alliés et elle même
séparé en deux à droite la rda
l'allemagne de l'est pays communiste à
gauche la rfa l'allemagne de l'ouest
pays capitalistes
quant à la ville de berlin situé au
coeur de l'allemagne de l'est elle est
partagée entre les 4e vainqueur de la
guerre
les soviétiques qui s'attribue la plus
grande partie font tout pour chasser les
occidentaux de cette enclave dans leur
territoire
en août 1961 moscou où le gouvernement
est allemand décide de construire un mur
qui encercle les omd à lille
ils veulent mettre fin à l'exode massif
des allemands de l'est qui passe à
l'ouest où les conditions de vie sont
bien meilleurs
[Musique]
yvan kuzmin jeune officier du kgb les
services secrets de l'union soviétique
est en poste à berlin ce 12 août 1961
sous couverture de la stasi les services
secrets de l'allemagne de l'est
l'opération a été menée à deux heures du
matin
le téléphone a sonné et on m'a dit de me
rendre au travail
j'ai compris pendant huit heures j'étais
chargé de parcourir la ville dans tous
les sens en voiture et d'évaluer la
situation dans la population on pouvait
craindre pour le lendemain le lundi
qu'il y ait des normes rassemblements de
foules en certains endroits stratégiques
comme sous
d'autres comme si on en juge par les
communiqués de la police et du ministère
de la sécurité d'état c'est à dire les
services secrets c'était vraiment calme
pas pour longtemps le 27 octobre 1961
les garde-frontière est-allemand veulent
contrôler les papiers des américains qui
se rendent en 7h soviétique
cette exigence est contraire au droit de
libre circulation dont bénéficient les
forces d'occupation
conséquence 10 chars américains et dix
chars soviétiques prennent position de
part et d'autre du mur à check point
charlie l'un des rares points de passage
le face à face dure trois jours mais il
ne se passe rien
la tension a atteint son paroxysme deux
ans plus tard le 26 juin 1963 avec la
visite à berlin du président des états
unis john kennedy qui apporte son
soutien aux habitants de berne
tous les hommes libres
ils vivent
sont des citoyens de berlin
c'est ainsi qu'en tant qu'homme libre je
suis fier de prononcer ces mots spn anne
perrine je suis un berlinois
[Applaudissements]
symbole de la guerre froide de la
confrontation est-ouest berlin devient
alors le terrain de chasse favori des
espions
werner grosse manette en 1984 l'adjoint
de markus wolf le patron de la stasi
et les chargés du recrutement des
espions
et jacques anziutti
signal je veux dire que pendant ces
années là nous avons pu recruter un
grand nombre d'agents ou comme nous
l'aimions
ils occupaient des positions influentes
dans la république fédérale
nous connaissions les décisions les plus
importantes qui a été prise concernant
la politique de l'allemagne de l'ouest
vis-à-vis de la rda et de l'union
soviétique
nous pouvions recevoir des informations
en temps réel ou bien très vite après
qu'elle ait été prise
nous pouvions donc réagir aussitôt en
transmettant ces informations à la
direction du parti et de l'état
gabriel gast fait partie de ces agents
secrets dans le cadre de ses études elle
est autorisée comme d'autres étudiants à
se rendre à berlin est pour travailler
sur sa thèse c'est là qu'elle est
approché par deux hommes et un homme
s'appelait muller l'autre s'était
présenté sous le nom de schmidt
s'était en réalité karlheinz schreiber
un collaborateur des services secrets
extérieurs de la stasi
avec lui j'ai entre lui et moi une
relation personnelle s'est développée ça
a été le point de départ car mon
recrutement la stasi
markus wolf le maître espion est
allemands s'intéressent à cette jeune
femme
il l'a fait venir clandestinement à
berlin
il l'a rencontré à plusieurs reprises
[Musique]
markus wolf avait depuis un certain
temps une idée en tête cette idée
c'était que dans le contexte d'une
recherche d'emploi je tente de me faire
recruter par les services secrets ouest
allemands le bnd une région b and you
came
j'ai réussi notre royaume
je suis entré au bnd et j'ai été affecté
dans le service d'analysé politique
spécialisé sur l'union soviétique est en
jaune
pour la stasi c'était un énorme succès
que je sois employé l'a dit j'ai
transmis au service est allemand pendant
des années toutes les informations
politiques qui intéresse c'est mon
secteur de travail
une liaison par un courrier avait été
mise en place cela veut dire que la
stasi on voyait toutes les quatre
semaines un agent chez moi à munich
et monte est en train le train de la
zone soviétique en direction de la rda
où il mettait les photos que j'avais
fait dans un container qu'il cachait
dans les toilettes toilettes
les containers étaient ensuite vidé de
l'autre côté de la frontière par la
stasi à farako les ath
[Musique]
si les services secrets de l'allemagne
de l'est recruter un filtre beaucoup
l'agent dans les administrations ou les
ministères à l'ouest l'un vers ce n'est
pas vrai selon hans georg sick
il était patron du bnd les services
secrets de l'allemagne de l'ouest
dit que nous n'avions que quelques
agents infiltrés à l'est n'étaient pas
en nombre élevé mais placé au bon
endroit il est bien plus difficile de
pénétrer dans un système fermé comme
celui de l'allemagne de l'est que dans
une société ouverte comme la république
fédérale d'allemagne la france ou la
grande-bretagne
à berlin est le ministère de la sécurité
d'état et les services secrets qui
occupe tout un quartier de la ville sont
un pilier essentiel du régime
la stasi est omniprésente
durant cette période milton bird et
responsable de la section pays de l'est
à la cia les services secrets américains
si quatre allemands de l'est buvaient
une bière dans un bistrot
ils savaient tous les quatre que l'un
d'entre eux travaillaient pour la stasi
il avait un système de taupes qui était
extrêmement pernicieux et tout le monde
en allemagne de l'est nous savaient ils
savaient que s'ils avaient eu un contact
avec une seule personne n'était possible
que cette personne soit une taux de la
stasi et cette personne le même être
lent femme ou bien leur mariage has been
de ses bureaux bunker à berlin la stasi
jr 91 mille fonctionnaires et 190 milles
indicateurs pour 16 millions d'habitants
forte de ses antennes les points gré de
ses centres d'interrogatoire les points
rouges de ses prisons les points noirs
sur tout le territoire de la rda elle
peut juguler la moindre opposition
il lui suffit d'incarcérer les ennemis
du socialisme dans ces prisons comme
celle de hunchun à berlin
où sony s 10 espions arrêtés à
checkpoint charlie porteur de documents
secrets il est resté seize ans dans les
geôles de la stasi
martha qui caractérisaient rosa nous
sommes c'est l isolement total
il y avait des fenêtres opaque on
pouvait juste deviner le forez l'aisne
on avait pas de livres on n'avait pas de
journaux on n'avait pas le droit d'avoir
le moindre bout de papier on n'avait pas
le droit de se coucher sur le fait on
avait seulement le droit de s'asseoir
sur un tassement on avait bien sûr pas
le droit de parler après 20 jours
d'isolement total c'est certainement une
méthode fantastique pour faire parler
qui que ce soit l'être humain a besoin
d'interlocuteurs
on estime que plus de 200 mille
personnes sont passées par les prisons
de la stasi
comment vivre dans un tel climat de
suspicion généralisée
pendant 27 ans des milliers d'allemands
de l'est n'ont qu'une idée franchir le
mur passer à l'ouest
mille cent trente-cinq personnes vont
tomber sous les balles des vopos la
police du peuple
la première victime un jeune homme de 24
ans est tué quelques semaines seulement
après la construction du mur
la dernière le sort à neuf mois avant sa
chute
au fil des ans
plus de 5000 citoyens de rda ont
néanmoins gagné la liberté par tous les
moyens imaginables
petit à petit le pays se vide de son
sang
l'économie de la rda commençait à se
détériorer
les gens qui fuyaient étaient
essentiellement des gens qualifiés et
dans toute une série de branche on a
commencé à manquer de spécialistes
pourtant le système avec sa jeunesse
embrigader ces manifestations de ferveur
populaire tout stalinienne aurait pu
perdurer de nombreuses années encore
mais une série d'événements va fissurer
le rideau de fer
le premier c'est l'élection d'un pape
polonais jean paul ii
le 2 juin 1979 et se rendent à son pays
natal
le général votre chèque jardin ce qui
est alors ministre de la défense dans le
gouvernement communiste qui dirige la
pologne
je me sens vivante broco show vice de
forme c'était une visite très importante
non seulement sur le plan religieux mais
aussi sur le plan social politique et
pour l'état
voire négatives pour des raisons
évidentes la réaction a été négative
même très critique non seulement de la
part de près je n'ai fait de l'union
soviétique mais dans tous les pays du
bloc et agdal et ils ont tous considéré
ce voyage du pape comme un sérieux coup
porté au système un coup susceptible de
remettre en cause certains principes
socialistes
la critique était aussi adressé au
pouvoir polonais qui avait facilité
l'élection du pape par sa politique de
tolérance religieuse
la réaction du bloc socialiste n'échappe
pas au service secret américain
joe biden agent de la cia est à cette
époque analystes en allemagne fédéral
direct l'élection du pape jean paul ii
en
1978 a été un véritable désastre pour
l'union soviétique
le premier voyage qui l'a fait en
pologne
lorsqu'il s'est adressé à eux deux
millions de personnes il a arrêté son
homélie regardé la foule et il a dit
vous êtes la véritable pologne ils ont
dû avoir une crise cardiaque au kremlin
pour le pape la véritable pologne c'est
l'apollonide des fidèles des catholiques
dans un pays où la puissance de l'église
est réel
davoudi niveau plat jean marc sauvé
avant ce mouvement vous n'imaginez pas
qu'on pouvait sortir dans la rue billy
éprouvé de la joie avec les autres
boutons piètre état c'était la première
étape pour se libérer de la peur
attendent notre charte et cela
signifiait le début de la fin du
communisme et communisme
c'est encore de pologne que vient un an
plus tard le deuxième coup de boutoir
qui va ébranler le bloc soviétique
une série de grèves éclatent la plus
dure au chantier lénine de gdansk
entreprises phares de la pologne
populaire avec ses seize mille ouvriers
lech walesa un électricien s'impose à la
tête du mouvement il a 36 ans
vient d'en manger nous à gdansk qui
avions le plus d'expérience dans la
lutte parce qu'il y avait déjà eu les
révoltes de 1970 mais vous les hommes
servir tout ce qui se passait dans le
pays et nous sommes arrivés à la
conclusion qu'il fallait fédérer tous
les mouvements de grève nous avons
organisé la classe ouvrière et nous y
avons ajouté toutes les professions les
médecins les acteurs les écrivains les
journalistes et nous avons invité au
chantier naval des caméras du monde
entier
dès les premiers arrêts de travail le sb
les services secrets intérieurs polonais
sont sur place
via soif poznanski et responsable de la
région de la baltique
je suis allé à dans son chantier pour
voir ce qui se passait bien sûr
je dois vous dire même si je ne devrais
peut-être pas vous le dire je disposais
d'une carte de presse comme couverture
nous savions qu'un scénario bien précis
été réalisé le même que celui qui
n'avait pas marché en 1970
derrière ce scénario derrière tout ça il
ya vait l'occident d'une manière
générale il y avait la cia l'espionnage
américain taylor et aussi des
financements du vatican et d'autres
sources à travers les syndicats ouvriers
etc
il y avait donc un financement très
important qui venait de l'autre côté tom
gbagbo souligne un
financement étranger ou pas devant la
paralysie générale de l'économie
polonaise et les pénuries alimentaires
le pouvoir entamer des pourparlers
lech walesa fort du soutien de millions
de travailleurs se révèle un négociateur
coriace
et provisions disputeront leur a dit
vous nous avez toujours menti et vous
allez continuer à mentir toute la nation
presque toute la nation vous dit on ne
veut plus de vous vous n'êtes pas nous
représentant les en cd nous avons forcé
les communistes à reconnaître par écrit
la création d'un nouveau mouvement
syndical indépendant du parti et du
pouvoir
solidarnosc qu tel est son nom voit le
jour le 31 août 1980 le syndicat compte
très vite 10 millions d'adhérents dans
tous les secteurs de la société
polonaise
à moscou surtout dans les services
secrets on comprend la portée de cet
événement
nicolas et léonov est alors directeur
des informations extérieures du kgb
bagdad nous disions kgb de manière nette
mais à vrai dire de manière assez risqué
pour cette époque que le socialisme en
pologne venait de subir une défaite
andropov nous demander
mais pourquoi le pensez vous nous
disions parce que le parti a perdu le
peuple il a perdu l'influencent sur le
peuple
en a deux sur quoi tient le pouvoir
alors nous disions le pouvoir socialiste
tient en pologne sur la carcasse nos
carcasse nakache
devant l'ampleur du mouvement les
distributions de tracts les appels
incessants la grève les services secrets
polonais qui ont infiltré solidarité
sont paralysés
on
sait le syndicat était infiltré bien sûr
que oui infiltrez ya un degré élevé
mais comme c'était un mouvement de masse
et ça il ne faut pas l'oublier
cette infiltration ne servait pas à
grand chose
calomnie sauveteurs le pouvoir l'époque
était conscient que si on avait dû
réagir de manière efficace tous les
actes de provocation dont on nous
informer il aurait fallu s'orienter vers
une autre erreur gigantesque
général joseph ce qui devenu premier
ministre en 1981 est pris en tenaille
entre les aspirations démocratiques du
peuple polonais et le grand frère
soviétique
il est convoqué à moscou le 5 décembre
de la même année les honneurs avec
lesquels la momie leonid brejnev
accueille le premier ministre polonais
cache la teneur réelle des entretiens
est out le signe de ft c'est une
prochaine news tinarrage dans cette
réunion ils ont émis un jugement très
critique sur la situation en pologne au
vote que les slides je tenais à ce que
le covan ils ont souligné que ce n'était
plus seulement une affaire interne à la
pologne
mais que la situation avait une
influence sur la sécurité de tout le
bloc soviétique
non ils ont laissé entendre pas de
manière explicite mais assez clairement
tout de même que si les choses
continuent ainsi le bloc soviétique
devraient intervenir en forte chute
qu'il était impossible de s'appuyer sur
qui que ce soit à part sur la police et
l'armée
et dans ces structures de force la seule
personne qui suscité le respect était
jaruszalski ainsi nos conversations avec
lui concerner le fait qu'il allait
sûrement joué le rôle du sauveur de
l'unité de la pologne
viel qui y est chaleureuse pour les
vieilles machines y'a qu'à spa damier ce
rôle le général jaruzelski l'assument il
apparaît en uniforme à la télévision
proclame le contrôle militaire de la
pologne l'interdiction des grèves et la
suppression des libertés fondamentales
les images font le tour du monde now na
et la pch à la passerelle audio
c'est cet homme le général chez soi vkii
ce chat ministre de l'intérieur et
patron des services de sécurité qui met
le plan à exécution
les chars investissent varsovie
en
quelques heures cette solidarité de 10
millions de membres se disperser il n'y
a pas eu que j'aimerais bien le préciser
d'arrestations il y a eu des
internements l'internement c'était un
moyen frais intermédiaires entre une
arrestation et une détention
l'opposition était contrôlée par l'eau à
100% nous avions client n'était membres
quelles étaient ces structures qui
faisait tourner les imprimeries
clandestines qu'est-ce qu'on a un prix
mais nous savions d'où provenait l'aide
financière à tout moment nous étions
capables de mettre la main dessus il
aurait été possible en intensifiant les
répressions de liquider l'opposition
plus nous ne l'avons pas fait car il
était plus facile de contrôler que de
les quitter
pour valérie redskins qui résident du
kgb à varsovie à ce moment là
ce contrôle du syndicat solidarité n'est
pas très efficace
s'adressant je n'ai pas constaté que le
gouvernement polonais lutte est très
fort entre solidarité
de manière très agressive vous avez
réussi barros et les dames je ne les ai
pas vus
c'est à dire qu'ils menaient des
opérations doucement contre solidarité
il fermait bien sûr quelques bureaux
mais comment les fermes et il cela se
passait ainsi les services secrets la sb
arrivée les policiers entraient il
mettait tout le monde dort puis
calmement il fallait d'abord mettez des
cadenas et l'affairé était close ils
n'ont mené personne parce qu'il s'en
foutait
des mille militants sont tout de même
arrêté la police l'armée la milice
boucle les secteurs clés et fermé les
frontières
la pologne
prendre dans le giron soviétique
en rda
erich honecker qui dirige le pays depuis
1971 suit les événements chez son voisin
polonais
mais ils se sont préservés à l'abri
derrière le mur qui a été modernisé
sécuriser
les abords ont été dégagés
des segments en béton ont remplacé les
parpaings des débuts
un no man's land a été installé ainsi
que plusieurs rangées de barrières
électriques et un éclairage permanent la
nuit
erich honecker tient son pays d'une main
de fer
et les taux mieux avec les grands
vieillards qui se succèdent au kremlin
brejnev andropov tchernenko
il partage d'ailleurs avec un grand
secret dont une fred hyman colonel de
l'armée allemande découvre les détails
dans les archives de la stasi
viam aut bien marrant ce que nous avons
trouvé plein ce sont des plans pour la
mobilisation la préparation est
l'invasion de l'allemagne de l'ouest y
au prat iongi nouvelle invasion de
berlin-ouest aurait été la seule
opération militaire menée par des
allemands de l'est avec toutefois une
participation soviétique
selon le régime un de défense aérienne
40 auraient eu pour tâche d'occuper les
deux grands aéroports tegel et appellera
donc de tenir immédiatement les points
stratégiques de l'ouest
aujourd'hui encore les anciens de la
stasi n'en parlent pas volontiers
certains savent qu'ils s'exposeraient
peut-être à des poursuites judiciaires
ces plans ont existé jusqu'à la fin de
la rda
en réalité à partir de 1985 la mise en
oeuvre de ces plans devient improbable
car une ère nouvelle s'ouvre à moscou
mais gaël gorbatchev nouveau secrétaire
général du parti communiste lance la
classe quand c'est la pérestroïka
transparence et couvertures
surtout il abandonne la doctrine brejnev
les pays satellites de l'urss doivent
désormais prendre leur destin en main
non au chili il est beau le pouvoir a
commencé de changer chez eux grâce dutil
les peuples ont acquis le droit de
choisir leur mode de fonctionnement leur
régime leur pouvoir ils ont obtenu la
possibilité de résoudre leurs problèmes
eux mêmes au niveau de leur constitution
cela a une importance cruciale
un vent d'air frais commence à souffler
derrière le rideau de fer
mais à moscou la situation de gorbatchev
ne semble pas aussi assuré que cela
surtout au sein de ses propres services
secrets
lors de mes séjours en union soviétique
le chef du kgb a donné une réception
solennelle à l'occasion de mon arrivée
il a porté le premier toast en proposant
de boire à la santé du leader polonais
du général jaruzelski
alors évidemment tout le monde s'est
levé tout le monde a bu et tout le monde
a applaudi
quelques minutes j'ai pensé qu'il serait
bon de porter un toast à mon tour et
j'ai porté un toast à la santé du leader
de l'union soviétique chef du parti
communiste de l'urss à gorbatchev vous
s'il en est ainsi dans une profonde
personne ne s'est levé personne n'a
applaudi et personne n'a but ce n'était
pas de la malveillance c'était de la
pure hostilité envers gorbatchev
carte politique en tant qu'homme
politique d'après l'idée que je me fais
d'un homme politique
gorbatchev n'avait absolument aucune
volonté il était d'une veulerie son nom
des affiches du coup c'était une poupée
de chiffon et en plus un incroyable
poltron il lui arrivait de s'énerver
quand il était mis en difficulté mais
cela n'allait jamais vraiment bien loin
gorbatchev savait que ses services
principalement le kgb ne voulait pas de
ces réformes alors il cherchait à les
contourner il ya eu donc un chaos
organisationnel le problème était de
savoir qui allait en profiter et c'est
nous qui en avons profité nous étions
plus rapides
gorbatchev prenait ses décisions plus
lentement moi et beaucoup d'autres nous
savions bien que le communisme était
irréformable
c'est pourquoi on la cité à faire des
réformes on applaudit c'est parce qu'on
savait que ça allait déclencher certains
processus et que le communisme allait
s'écrouler et c'est ce qui s'est fait
taxer star
un autre événement à l'autre bout du
monde ébranle un peu plus le vieil
édifice communiste
l'armée rouge qui s'est emparée de
l'afghanistan 1979
est en train de subir une cuisante
défaite
en 1986 milton birds and est en mission
pour la cia au pakistan
et les chargés de fournir en argent
armes et entraînement aux afghans contre
les soviétiques
c'était impossible de gagner mais
il n'aurait jamais pu avoir suffisamment
de troupes en afghanistan pour parvenir
à contrôler le pays il aurait eu besoin
de cinq cent mille soldats et ils ne
disposaient pas de cinq cent mille
soldats
lorsque gorbatchev prononça son discours
à vladivostok en 1986 et qu'il qualifie
à l'afghanistan de plaies sanguinolentes
il avait déjà pris à ce moment là la
décision de quitter le pays mais la
pression de l'armée étaient trop
importantes et son arrivée au pouvoir
trop récent
alors il aura donné un an pour changer
la face des choses et elle était le
sujet de discussion au politburo entre
1986 et 1996 c'était c'était soit de
donner à l'armée une année de plus ou
bien il fallait se retirer
14 mai soldat de l'armée rouge vont
laisser leur vie dans le bourbier afghan
avant que le pouvoir à moscou ne décide
de se retirer du pays
[Musique]
le 29 février 1989 le dernier char russe
quitte l'afghanistan
c'est le vietnam de l'urss
au même moment pologne un nouveau coup
est porté au système soviétique le
syndicat solidarité se reconstituent
dans la clandestinité
même si l'enthousiasmé militants des
débuts n'est plus au rendez vous quant
au pouvoir communiste il est carrément à
bout de souffle et
celui d'areva en fait solidarité était
trop faible pour prendre le pouvoir et
le pouvoir était trop faible pour mener
les changements économiques absolument
nécessaire très difficile pénible mais
il faut dire que la société ne voulait
pas de ces réformes
le gouvernement communiste et le
syndicat solidarité sont dos au mur ils
n'ont qu'une solution négociée
c'est la fameuse table ronde
les deux parties s'engagent dans
l'organisation des premières élections
libres dans un pays du rideau de fer
ces élections doivent en théorie aboutir
à un partage du pouvoir favorable
communiste la réalité est tout autre
les services secrets polonais le sb
connaissent eux les véritables
intentions des dirigeants de solidarité
au chômage mais pas sans nous ont posé
des écoutes dans des chambres sur le
téléphone
on utilisait des techniques
opérationnelles ça s'appelait ainsi
on utilisait aussi des gens comme source
d'information on transmettait les
informations recueillies au pouvoir mais
celui ci bien sûr ne nous disait pas ce
qu'il comptait faire de tout ça
nous avons sur ainsi que de l'autre côté
de la table ronde il n'y avait pas de
volume
c'est à dire il n'y avait pas de volonté
de respecter les accords
c'est ça il voulait rafler la mise en
fait le pouvoir compter sur la loyauté
de ce qu'était de l'autre côté de la
table ronde et il s'est avéré que cet
autre côté n'avait pas du tout envie de
se comporter loyalement
c'était la preuve la naïveté du pouvoir
je n'ai jamais trop voulu parler de ce
sujet j'ai longtemps évité les
entretiens auxquels j'étais invité car
cela me mettait dans une situation un
peu délicate
en fait je suis un homme bien élevé
honnête qui respecte sa parole moi je
n'ai pas pu jouer honnêtement dans cette
affaire parce qu'il fallait que je sois
d'accord pour la table ronde lui demain
j'ai signé j'ai donné mon accord et dans
ma tête je pensais
il faudra voir tout ça on ne peut pas
accepter ça on ne peut pas quand on
signe des accords ils doivent être
respectées alors moi je ne suis pas un
exemple à suivre
le mieux serait de ne pas parler de ça
mais c'est déjà fusé
aux élections qui suivent la table ronde
les communistes perdent tout il se
croyait pourtant protégés par le système
législatif complexe qu'ils avaient
imposées
pour la première fois dans un pays du
bloc soviétique
un non communiste tadeus mazowiecki va
diriger un gouvernement
la tentation du coup de force est alors
vivent
des personnes à l'extrême gauche qui
voulait annuler les élections et y
revenir à l'ancien régime
il
y en avait aussi l'extrême droite je le
mentionnais ou qu'un nom qui proposait
aussi d'annuler les élections en valais
on imaginer des bords
en théorie c'était possible et quelque
part en marge je le souligne en marge
des tentations de ce genre apparaissait
nous avions de notre côté l'armée la
sécurité le parti j'avais la guerre de
suprême de l'armée on aurait pu
continuer ça aurait été une mauvaise
chose et risqué mais c'était possible
le communisme vient d'être balayée en
pologne
dans le même temps en hongrie un autre
pays vassal de l'urss
vent de changement se met à souffler
janusz cadart au pouvoir depuis 30 ans a
fait son temps surtout il ne cache pas
son scepticisme devant la pérestroïka
que tente d'imposer gorbatchev
boris moussa tough ambassadeurs du rsc
sont gris dans les années 80 est présent
lors de l'entretien entre kadaré
gorbatchev
alors que gorbatchev discourait sur
l'avenir de la pérestroïka cadart lui a
dit comme ça le l'air de rien tout ça
c'est très bien mais cahill sergei beach
mais est ce que vous ne craignez pas de
subir le même sort que khrouchtchev
je veux dire un complot contre le monde
sait qu'en bas de chef est resté pantois
puis avec à rire forcé il a dit qu'il
prenait pour plus bêtes que khrouchtchev
ou quoi j'ai tout prévu j'ai la question
n'avait pas été posée par hasard
si gorbatchev et canards ne sont pas
dans les meilleurs termes
en revanche les chefs de leur service
secret s'entendent comme larrons en
foire
rares sont les images on les voit
ensemble
ici janusz bogui patron des services
secrets ont droit aux côtés de markus
wolf ex-chef de la stasi et gorbatchev
bien écrit ocz cov patron du kgb nommé
par gorbatchev
un an après cette séquence inédite
tournée par un amateur dans une datcha
de la campagne hongroise
kadaré mis sur la touche et la jeune
garde du parti communiste 30 pouvoir
miklos nemeth devient premier ministre
il a à peine 40 ans le jour de son
investiture
nous soignons 220 barousse on aille à
décaisser 24 novembre 1988 je prête
serment je signe les documents et je
retourne dans mon
l'ambassadeur de l'urss et là il
m'attend dans mon bureau et il me
présente une invitation à moscou michael
morse quoi il a togo tâche
c'était comme ça
le nouveau dirigeant devait s'y rendre
dès le lendemain de sa prise de fonction
h tél
papa j'ai remercié l'ambassadeur de
l'urss de son invitation mais je lui ai
expliqué que je ne pouvais pas m'y
rendre avant que le budget du pays
seraient à
des choses ou une ampoule je me suis
servi de ce prétexte pour rompre avec la
tradition c'est pour gagner du temps
côtoyer de tenir avec
c'est en mars 1989 seulement qu'à miklos
nemeth se rend à moscou
ils vont informer gorbatchev d'une
décision qui vient de prendre une
décision qui va se révéler déterminante
dans les événements à venir
et non en fait
j'ai décidé de rayer du budget et le
maintien du rideau de fer ce barbelé qui
sépare l europe de manière anachronique
nous n'avions pas le budget pour
maintenir ce système électrique qu'il
fallait renouveler
cela aurait coûté une fortune dont la
hongrie ne disposait pas
la réaction de gorbatchev a été très
intéressante aux quand je lui ai annoncé
ma décision
il regardait loin devant lui et il m'a
dit deux choses
que notre système socialiste fonctionne
très bien
que chaque pays devait prendre ses
propres responsabilités des communes
il a ajouté
je ne comprends pas d'ailleurs en quoi
cette affaire est essentiel pour viard
problème en ligne monteux
devant ce feu vert du grand frère
soviétique les hongrois arrache une
ligne de barbelés et coupent
l'électricité sur les 270 kilomètres de
la frontière qui sépare leur pays de
l'autriche
cette clôture est d'une redoutable
efficacité
en vingt ans sur les 13500 tentative de
fuite vers l'ouest seuls 300 ont réussi
harper bellaïd fans franco faisait
partie de l'état-major des
gardes-frontières de la région de son
trône
[Musique]
total
nous sommes à la frontière occidentale
près du lac certeau qui était une zone
interdite à l'époque
elle s'étendait sur huit à dix
kilomètres entre les montagnes et le lac
est accessible que pour des personnes
non autorisées des pêcheurs des
chasseurs et des ramasseurs de roseaux
c'était pour la plupart des
gardes-frontière bénévoles ou volontaire
je veux dire des informateurs qui nous
faciliter le travail
ils ont attrapé pas mal de gens qui
essayait de passer la frontière
à la suite d'une démontage du système
électrique
les frontières ne pouvait plus être
surveillées comme avant et pourtant
c'est ce que nos chefs attendait de nous
rentable c'était un non sens de tous les
points de vue les choses
la hongrie devient le maillon faible du
bloc communiste car sa frontière
occidentale n'est plus hermétique
cette situation inquiète pour deux
raisons
la première
deux cent mille soldats de l'armée
soviétique stationnement
la seconde est un secret d'état que
laszlo danko chef du contre-espionnage
hongrois est l'un des seuls à connaître
jeunes a tenu à tour 59 ans surveillant
mais en suivant les attachés militaires
et les espions des pays de l'otan nous
avions détecté différentes bases
nucléaires soviétiques qu'ils
espionnaient sur notre territoire
nous avions remarqué qu'ils effectué 70
à 80% de leurs allées et venues dans les
mêmes régions faut qu'on soit trop tard
qu'aimerais tu as choisi ce que nous
ignorons encore aujourd'hui je sais
comment eux avaient appris où se
trouvaient les bases nucléaires et les
manques fr d'un litige
ce secret mais klaus nemeth le premier
ministre hongrois la prends quelques
semaines après sa prise de pouvoir
lorsqu'il est conduit dans une pièce
sécurisée du ministère de la défense
il y avait de l'eau s'y est préparée sur
une table on les a ouverts et l'un était
en droit l'autre en russie tournent
c'était écrit à la main il s'agissait de
l'accord conclu dans les années 1969 70
centres cadart et les dirigeants
soviétiques de l'époque mal à la peau
bâche lynagh et il l'atteint n est pour
toutes au maroc diacre de sembène arrive
à temps j'ai appris à ce moment là que
contrairement au discours officiel
au beau lot au nord du lac balaton
dollars quelque part dans les montagnes
vols à bas carbone
il y avait des missiles balistiques
soviétique
attendent toute attaque à faire avec
leurs charges nucléaires ou balistiques
aux chocs et ac
lors d'un voyage à moscou en est et 1989
miklos nemeth obtient de gorbatchev le
retrait à terme des armes nucléaires et
des soldats de l'armée soviétique
nous sommes au début des vacances et
quand chaque année les allemands de
l'est viennent ici en vrai elle sillonne
le pays dans leur voiture des trabant
bringuebalante et envahissent les
campings du danube ou du lac balaton
les espions de la stasi sont à l'affût
ils se mêlent aux estivants
maria qui vagues au fonctionnaire dans
le contre espionnage hongrois été
chargée des contacts avec eux
échoppes acheter assez sèche matin et
les agents de la stasi passait devant
les maisons au lac balaton et quand ils
voyaient dans le même jardin une voiture
immatriculée ddr c'est à dire en
allemagne de l'est et une autre
immatriculé en rf 1 en allemagne de
l'ouest il faisait un rapport
à l'écran le citoyen d'allemagne de
l'est rentré chez lui on l'interrogeait
on lui demandait qui l'avait rencontré
en hongrie où il avait habité et ses
rôles à quoi en fonction de ces réponses
ou bien essayé de le recruter ou bien
ils n'étaient plus autorisés à la
hongrie
à 7 et 89
les agents de la stasi venez nous voir
plus souvent qu'avant
la raison est simple les photos des
gardes frontières hongrois coupant les
barbelés attire un grand nombre
d'allemands de l'est
la stasi et donc sur les dons comme le
constate à ce moment là infranor vaz
ministre de l'intérieur hongrois
les allemands de l'est voulait qu'on
continue la pratique des années d'avant
c'est à dire que tous ceux qui avaient
essayé de passer illégalement en
autriche en yougoslavie
devait être rendu aux autorités
est-allemandes et reconduits chez eux en
groupe par avion
mais en étaient 89 nous n'avons plus
respectifs cet accord bilatéral et
d'action
conséquence des allemands de l'est se
ruent dans l'ambassade de rfa il demande
l'asile politique et un passeport
d'autres cherchent le soutien des
organisations caritatives et des églises
le berck osm a été curé à budapest
c'était comme un déluge
on ne pouvait pas s'y préparer
en quelques jours les rues de la ville
était envahie par des allemands de l'est
dans les parcs il y avait des centaines
de tentes nous avons essayé de les aider
avec les moyens du bord
[Musique]
dès le 5e jour l'ambassade de rfa s'est
installée dans l'église c'est ici qu'on
leur a délivré leur passeport mais avec
l'arrivée du consulat les agents des
services secrets ouest allemands sont
arrivés aussi
quand les espions de l'ouest arrive ceux
de l'est ne tarde pas
la stasi road au temps du temps ces
agents sont même surpris en train de
photographier les réfugiés
et best of ce qui est certain c'est
qu'ils étaient aussi présents au sein du
camp mais les réfugiés était très
méfiant déjà entre eux ils ne se
parlaient pas
les premiers quinze jours il était très
renfermé méfiants ils avaient peur des
informateurs
il ne savait pas si leurs voisins de
tank n'était pas un mouchard
les officiers de liaison de la stasi qui
venaient me voir sous prétexte de
bavardage c'était un homme et une femme
est complet
il me demandait en permanence des
informations sur le nombre d'allemands
de l'est qui séjournaient dans les camps
sur le nombre de gens susceptibles de
faire des tentatives pour passer la
frontière
nous avons senti qu'il était de plus en
plus nerveux l'occupation de l'ambassade
de la rfa surtout les irriter beaucoup
le père kosma
reçoit un jour une visite inattendue
le consul de la rda est venu me voir car
il voulait prendre contact avec les
réfugiés
je lui ai tout de suite dit oui
je lui ai demandé pour quelle raison
il a répondu qu'il voulait les informer
que tout le monde pouvait rentrer en rda
sans poursuites à leur retour
j'ai donc fait venir une caravane qui a
été stationné sur le trottoir en dehors
du camp pour le consul est-allemand j'ai
dit aux consuls quincy il pourrait
recevoir ceux qui voudraient bien le
voir
personne n'a voulu le voir naturel
janusz sold their journalistes pour la
télévision allemande ard était là jeudi
se sont mis à lancer des pierres sur la
caravane ils ont écrit stasi et puis
l'ont renversé donc la stasi a été
contrainte de se retirer de la proximité
du camp moins officiellement
ce que nous craignons c'est que la
situation devienne ingérable
pour cette raison j'ai dit plusieurs
fois aux allemands de l'est que c'était
leur problème
il fallait qu'ils sachent que nous
allions laisser sortir les réfugiés car
les premières gelées allait arriver et
les gens ne pourraient pas dormir dehors
mais klaus nemeth le premier ministre
hongrois décide alors de tester la
réaction de gorbatchev la seule qui
compte pour lui
ils montrent deux opérations la première
discrètement il s'agit d'un pique nique
organisé par le mouvement paneuropéen
gua à sopron sur la frontière
autrichienne
les services secrets angoua sont
derrière
par des canaux différents oui je veux
dire par là que nos services secrets se
sont servis de leur réseau et par ces
réseaux nous avons pu faire courir une
rumeur selon laquelle ça pourrait être
intéressant pour les allemands de l'est
d'aller à la frontière occidentale
non non je te
je me suis trouvé dans une situation
insoluble et quand j'ai demandé à mes
supérieurs ce que je devais faire
ils m'ont dit qu'ils ne disposaient
d'aucune information
selon eux rien ne confirme et que cette
foule viendrait à l'endroit du pique
nique
et pourtant la foule est bel et bien
arrivé
les services secrets était forcément
dans le coup il n'y avait que capable
d'organiser une entreprise aussi
importante
600 personnes se retrouvent devant la
dérisoire barrière de barbelés qui
sépare la hongrie de l'autriche
nouveautés jeux en quelques secondes
j'ai compris que je n'avais aucun moyen
de les empêcher d'une manière pacifique
c'était des gens déterminés à passer
je me suis dit que si j'intervenais il
me restait huit à dix secondes pas plus
et cela risquait de se terminer dans le
sang ils sont embarqués temps mais
je n'ai pas bougé et le groupe est
arrivé ici même à ce point de passage
devancé dont le cadenas n'était pas
fermée
sûr que la foule l'a retirée et ils ont
traversé la frontière
moment historique dont il n'existe
qu'une dizaine de photos
arpad bella
à l'essai plusieurs centaines de
personnes s'engouffrer dans la brèche
ils viennent de piétiner leurs rideaux
de fer
[Musique]
quelques jours plus tard une seconde
opération est organisée cette fois en
direct par les services secrets ont
droit il décide d'exfiltrer vers
l'allemagne de l'ouest les réfugiés de
l'ambassade de rfa
il fait dans le yunnan que nous avons
demandé de l'informer les réfugiés de
cette action une heure seulement avant
le départ
nous savions en effet que des
informateurs de la stasi était parmi
nous
voulions surtout pas qu'ils soient au
courant de cette action secret d'un logo
mais retrouve
l'interrogation suisse affrété par la
croix-rouge internationale
attendait sur la piste à 6
heures du matin nous avons fait monter
les réfugiés
l'avion a décollé coujoux et a quitté la
hongrie
à 2 heures du matin
une centaine de réfugiés sont accueillis
à vienne en autriche
sont des femmes et des enfants pour la
plupart car les hommes ont préféré
rester dans l'ambassade à budapest ils
craignaient un piège de la stasi
match complet kerviel ce bayonne le
lendemain matin
l'officier de liaison de la stasi est
venu me voir il était scandalisé il m'a
demandé si je savais ce qui s'était
passé cette nuit je lui ai dit que je
n'étais pas au courant de mon temps mais
même
pour la première fois la frontière
craque les deux opérations tests monté
par les hongrois sont positives
gorbatchev tient sa promesse lorsqu'on
n'a pas réagi
près d'un millier d'allemands de l'est
passe ainsi à l'ouest
miklos nemeth va donc plus loin
le 25 août et se rend sans en référer à
quiconque au château de guillaume
nietzsche près de cologne en allemagne
de l'ouest
là il rencontre le chancelier helmut
kohl
nicoletta mode je lui annonce est
carrément notre intention d'ouvrir les
frontières
l on ait de robert
cmmb les aides alors cet homme grand et
corpulent comme à regarder fixement sa
bulle et j'ai vu qu'il avait des larmes
dans les yeux le chancelier kohl
il m'a dit mais gros lot chou si cette
promesse se réalise
mais je n'ai pas moi
le couple
ne lira jamais cet acte de votre
gouvernement et de votre corps manioc et
sur madior fall est
pasteur et comme c'était un homme
politique avec plus d'expérience que moi
m'a demandé à trois reprises
si cette décision était bien prise en
accord avec
moscou
je lui ai ensuite demander de plus quand
son pays serait prêt à recevoir ces
dizaines de milliers de réfugiés
s'y préparer c'est même tout cas
personne ne savait combien de centaines
d'agents de la stasi
se trouvaient parmi ces gens que la rfa
à l'état considère qui est en
jeu
à partir de ce moment mais klaus nemeth
à la stasi sur le dos
mais ouais en fait une kippa teichmann
on m'a montré des photos de mes enfants
qui étaient à l'école maternelle
elle avait été prise par des agents de
la stasi ou dinosaures stasi une ne
lèche cul sur ces photos il y avait des
notes qui prouvait que mes enfants
étaient surveillés
ce qui laissait entendre que ma famille
était peut-être nana c'est
à partir de ce jour là pendant trois
semaines mes enfants ont été
accompagnées à l'école par les agents
des services secrets ou hongrois
et ma femme ne pouvais plus aller faire
ses courses le marché européenne des
règles ici
le premier ministre hongrois est aussi
devenu suspect aux yeux des durs du
parti communiste
car je me suis rendu compte un jour
le premier secrétaire du parti faisait
des romains ne s'adressant pas à moi
sur des informations dont je n'avais
parler qu'avec mes deux conseillers les
plus proches
j'étais intrigué j'espère d'aller
téchené
de les conseillers avaient un de ses
amis dans le contre espionnage de
l'armée
il est venu un soir avec ses instruments
kidal outre deuxième et il a trouvé
quatre micros installés dans mon bureau
et epeat microfaune au larvotto bananas
échec aux stocks et j marie ainsi j'ai
compris par quels moyens carole croûte
c'était lui le premier secrétaire du
parti communiste
connaissait les informations
confidentielles donc j'ai discuté avec
mes deux conseillers
mais je n'ai pas fait en vue des micros
mai à partir de ce jour là nous n'avons
plus aborder les questions sensibles que
dans des bureaux choisi
rien ne peut plus arrêter l'histoire en
marche le 11 septembre 1989 les réfugiés
du père cosma apprennent par la
télévision que le gouvernement hongrois
vient d'ouvrir la frontière
c'est la revue plus de 10000 allemands
de l'est gagnent la rfa en une semaine
cette fois un pan du rideau de fer vient
bel et bien de s'écrouler même si
personne ne peut encore prévoir ce qui
se prépare en rda
car à berlin le mur est toujours là et
bien là
il a encore été modernisée ces dernières
années réhaussé équipés de caméras de
détecteurs de présence de nouveaux
miradors
les chemins des vopos ont été élargies
et les rondes renforcer
le régime verrouille toujours autant la
société
la stasi est devenue championne dans les
technologies de surveillance
après il faut dissimuler mini-caméra
enregistrement à distance
son imagination est sans limite
résultat aucun dissident un peu actif
n'échappe à sa vigilance
naturellement nos unités du contre
espionnage ont toujours localisé les
dissidents au début lorsqu'il était
isolé et plus tard lorsqu'ils se sont
organisés ils ont été repérés et des
mesures étaient prises contre
est la mesure phare c'est toujours
emprisonnement
si dans les années 80 où wayne shaw now
zad les cellules ne sont plus dans les
sous sols elle reste sans ouverture les
prisonniers sont toujours à l'isolément
total et les méthodes n'ont pas changé
vera lengsfeld mais les tentes du
mouvement des droits civiques les à
expérimenter
elle est dans la cellule qu'elle a
occupée en 1988
j'ai été arrêté avec 120 autres
militants pour les droits civiques
dix jours après je suis passé devant le
tribunal et j'ai été condamné à six mois
de prison pour tentatives de préparation
d'émeutes
j'ai toujours été consciente qu'il y
avait des indics de la stasi dans mon
entourage
lorsque j'ai lu mon dossier plus tard
j'ai été étonné de voir combien il y en
avait il y en avait en tout 49
il savait tout sommet jusqu'aux savons
que j'utilisais le produit que
j'employais pour la vaisselle jeu bien
d'autres choses encore
ils savaient qu'ils me rendent est
visible dans mon appartement avec qui
j'étais ami etc etc
quelle pièce de théâtre j'allais voir
c'est ici au quatrième étage de
l'immeuble de la stasi à berlin que le
sort des allemands de l'est pouvait
basculer
le bureau d'eric mail que le ministre de
la sécurité d'état
il est resté tel qu'il était en 1989
ce standard mail que était en liaison
avec tous les responsables du système
grossman le saône adjoint chef de
l'espionnage
le comité central le gouvernement
l'armée et le fort national frogs armés
ici la saaq c'est à dire la section qui
s'occupait des gens qui voulaient partir
à l'ouest on pouvait brouillé aussi les
conversations ici
d'un simple coup de fil d'une parole en
réunion du comité de sécurité mais que
peut faire arrêter surveiller ou
écoutent et qui bon lui semble et ils ne
s'en privent pas
17h vehlmann diplomate ouest allemand en
poste à la délégation permanente une
sorte d'ambassade de rfa rda a été une
de ses cibles
on aura notre maison était constamment
surveiller notre téléphones écoutés nous
le savions
gelé constater personnellement
j'avais eu une conversation téléphonique
j'avais raccrocher le combiné et lorsque
j'ai voulu refaire mon appel j'ai
entendu ce que je venais de dire plus
d'un but
[Musique]
ces images rares tournées par la stasi
dans les années 80 servez à la formation
de ses agents
[Musique]
mais mu mérite agosta tout le monde
était heureux
le réseau était si important qu'il
pouvait tout entendre et en particulier
nos agents en allemane de l'ex
chacun de leurs mouvements et vous le
moindre bruit dans leur appartement tout
ce qui bougeait dans leur voiture était
écouté les allemands de l'est entendait
absolument tout
dans l'histoire de la cia y en ce qui
concerne l'allemagne de l'est nous
n'avons pas bien réussi c'était un
terrain particulièrement difficile et
pour nous d'autre part les nombreux
espions que nous avions était également
des agents tos barbeau
jusqu'à la fin la cia avait en tout 23
agents horaires d et sur ses 23 agents
22 étaient les agents doubles cela veut
dire que 22 travaillé aussi pour le
ministère de la sécurité et un seul
était un véritable agent de la cia
nous en revanche nous avons continué de
recevoir des informations jusqu'à la fin
de l'automne 1989 elle provenait de la
république fédérale et de berlin-ouest
et de toutes les institutions
de la chancellerie jusqu'au ministère
des affaires étrangères
parmi les espions infiltrés à l'ouest
gabriel gast poursuit tranquillement sa
carrière au bnd les services ouest
allemand
histoire vos chandails
javert bon standing au bénin dia
le travail que je faisais était reconnue
mana
on ne doutait pas de ma loyauté ne
serait ce qu'en raison de ma situation
familiale de mon mode de vie
tout se passait comme on dit dans la
meilleure tradition bourgeoise
j'ai transmis des informations à l'est
jusqu'à la fin de 1989 si je me souviens
bien
jusqu'en novembre m
je peux dire que le bnd n'a pas
pronostiqué que l'évolution irait vers
un écroulement de toute l'europe de
l'est jusqu'à la rda et belges à chine
le monde mais il semblait toujours
cimenté en deux blocs
ya aussi ces eps que tout d'un coup on
dira tout un pont de l'est implose de
l'intérieur cela semblait inconcevable
une force terrible
que ce soit le kgb la cia le bnd la
stasi les services secrets sont dans le
brouillard
mais leur attention se focalise sur
michael gorbatchev le premier secrétaire
du parti communiste de l'urss
combien de temps va-t-il encore se
maintenir au pouvoir car il prend de
plus en plus de risques
il était devenu clair que gorbatchev
n'avait aucune intention d'intervenir il
ne l'avait pas fait en hongrie ni en
tchécoslovaquie il ne le ferait pas en
allemagne de l'est ça c'était devenu
évident pour nous
les difficultés avec l'allemagne de
l'est s'intensifier alors gorbatchev a
dit à erich honecker il n'est pas
question d'envoyer des troupes il faudra
que vous vous en sortirez
l'année 1989 fut donc une année pendant
laquelle celui qui prêtait attention aux
événements se pouvait deviner ce qui
s'annonçait être certain que gorbatchev
ne seraient pas obligées d'intervenir
dans les pays de l'est
et mabhida pas défense taille avait
toujours la crainte de gorbatchev depuis
spa maintenir qu'on avait un jour ne
connaissions bien sa situation
le fait qu'ils aient été forcés de
supprimer le monopole du parti
communiste lors de la réforme de la
constitution soviétique en 1988 était
naturellement un gros risque pour lui
une grosse saisie qu il s'était fait
beaucoup d'adversaires mais les membres
du parti communiste
une guide
des opposants gorbatchev n'y en a pas
que dans son pays
en allemagne de l'est dans les bureaux
de la stasi mais il paye ses services
secrets verrait d'un bon oeil son
éviction du pouvoir
on
ne peut donc pas dire que milk coffe
jusqu'à la fin
une chorale choses à prouver gambazza
foot la politique de gorbatchev je
dirais ceci la pérestroïka oui ça il
encore contre il est aussi bien
accueillie mais l'adresse nost c'est à
dire la transparence ça ne valait rien
pour 1000 cas là il était absolument
contre
la situation était simple aux yeux 2015
il a dit tout bonnement que l'union
soviétique avait trahi la rda et que
gorbatchev avait trahi le communisme
il avait des formulations très directe
tout ce qui se passait en r d à cette
époque était la conséquence de cette
trahison cette part mais souvenons nous
l'avons créé avec l'aide de moscou 7 rda
mais hélas avec l'aide de moscou nous la
destruction
le camarade milk était le seul qui a dit
clairement que gorbatchev était un
traître que moscou avait trahi son
socialisme il était le seul à le dire de
manière claire et nette la turquie
quand michael gorbatchev arrive à berlin
le 7 octobre 1989 pour le 40e
anniversaire de la rda il sait ce que le
kgb les apparatchiks des pays frères
pense de lui
cela ne m'empêche pas dès sa première
rencontre avec la foule des journalistes
d'affirmer plus que jamais sa politique
yao film george town ou de chaque peuple
doit décider de son propre sort
nous connaissons bien nos amis allemands
nous leur faisons entièrement confiance
les dangers nuggets que ceux qui ne
réagissent pas à la finale
cette phrase est directement adressé à
honecker
alors que leur monde est en train de
s'écrouler le dialogue raïssa et michael
gorbatchev
margot et éric auclair est surréaliste
je suis sans doute berlin s'est soulevé
le camarade honecker m'a dit qu'une
radio occidentale a communiqué qu'il y
avait un soulèvement à berlin
il est un soulèvement effectivement
de toutes les générations
que veut dire gorbatchev a par l'un
d'eux soulèvement sait-il que depuis
quelques jours déjà d'énormes
manifestations ont lieu à berlin et dans
plusieurs villes du pays
la foule scande son nom se réclament de
la pérestroïka de la démocratie et
vitupère le régime n'est clair dont elle
ne vaut cru
sait-il que la police du peuple frappent
les manifestants et que la stasi
interpelle encore à tour de bras
non il pense plutôt à la foule des
jeunes bien alignées sur le trottoir au
passage de son cortège officiel
ces fêtes grandioses du 40e anniversaire
de la rda sont en réalité le chant du
cygne du régime communiste
la cérémonie de clôture
michael gorbatchev s'en souvient avec
nostalgie
vingt ans plus tard
me stober
ceux qui ont été là bas pour ce 40e
anniversaire ont vu tout ce qui se
passait en rda aider
toutes les 28 régions étaient présentes
c'était formidable
les flammes étaient portés par des
jeunes ou d'autres gens d'âge moyen
visait une fille le chantait faisait
beaucoup de bruit lancé des slogans
réunification réunification
en octobre 1989 la société sts allemande
est en ébullition
en plus des manifestations de rue chaque
lundi les églises protestantes à l'epsic
adresse se remplissent de fidèles venus
en principe prier pour la paix
la stasi ne bronche pas
la stasi ne voulait pas anéantir
complètement sa relation avec l'église
la stasi a toujours considéré l'église
comme un espace où justement les gens
étaient tout à fait prêt à coopérer
d'une manière ou d'une autre avec elle
peut-être pas directement avec la stasi
mais avec le régime
donc les gens propageait dans les
églises le message suivant nous voulons
manifester pacifiquement ne voulons pas
remettre en question le système nous
voulons encore moins immigrés mais nous
voulons rester ici en tant que citoyens
de la rda et nous voulons transformer ce
pays cette république là
d'astank bugs et la population dans les
mouvements de masse qui a provoqué la
chute le bas les dissidents les
dissidents je voulais renverser le
régime mais pour le remplacer par un
régime démocratique
il pensait qu'il était souhaitable
d'avoir deux états démocratiques
allemand dans l'intérêt de la sécurité
de l'europe leur idée de l'homme leur
idée de la république fédérale
d'allemagne étaient négatives
à ce stade de déstabilisation du régime
communiste en rda on se demande pourquoi
le kgb n'a pu prévenir ou en rayer le
processus pourtant il en avait les
moyens
boris laptev nous révèle qu'au début des
années 80 il dirige une cellule ultra
secrète du kgb à berlin l'unité loach
unité a existé jusqu'à la fin jusqu'à la
réunification avec la rfa renaat ciel au
début notre tâche n'était pas de
retarder tout processus d'effondrement
du régime en rda si cela arrivait mais
de l'empêcher
tout simplement et voilà qu'en ce
processus est devenu trop avancé lorsque
les événements ont pris une telle
tournure que la chute du régime et c'est
inévitable
là notre tâche a été de le retarder pour
que nous perdions le moins deux écoles
nos capteurs nous disions ok mais ça
doit être au moindre coût pour nous
l'ultime sursaut le kgb se réveille fin
octobre et nicolas et léonov est envoyé
en mission secrète à berlin est
quand on veut les minimoys ne pas
sélectionner nature à cette époque mon
chef direct vladimir alexandre urwicz
krioutchkov et général de l'armée qui
était depuis un certain temps déjà
président du kgb m'a dit vous devez
partir immédiatement vers des arts à
berlin est resté là le temps que vous
jugez nécessaire et vous devez me faire
un rapport
je me suis envolé pour berlin et là j'ai
vu un tableau de chaos le naufrage du
titanic sa
bile et tu ne peux pas m'imaginer
autrement la situation dans ce pays où
tout était pour ainsi dire en état
d'effondrement
aucun de mes interlocuteurs ne me disait
à l'époque que c'était la fin que
c'était le stade final
le représentant du kgb novikov et moi
nous nous sommes mis au travail et nous
avons écrit péniblement presque avec le
sang de nos propres veines une dépêche
destiné au comité central du parti
nous avons répondu à deux questions
essentielles qui nous ont été posées
nous avons écrit de façon directe
il n'est pas possible de garder la rda
comme état souverain
2 le régime socialiste en rda n'a pas de
perspective il va s'effondrer en gros
le parti communiste tente pourtant de
renverser la situation
les rénovateurs prennent le pouvoir
egon krenz remplace eric en équerre que
gorbatchev a lâché
mais c'est trop tard les allemands de
l'est n'ont plus peur
il aborde carrément la police du peuple
ce qui était impensable il ya quelques
semaines encore
quant aux agents de la stasi qui rôdent
autour des manifestants ils font profil
bas
et se détournent des journalistes
ils ne peuvent museler les caméras du
monde entier qui tourne à plein régime
la stasi a perdu pied
le 4 novembre près d'un million de
manifestants rassemblés sur alexander
platz exigent la liberté d'opinion la
liberté de la presse la liberté de
réunion
à la direction des services secrets on
comprend que la partie est jouée
nous avons commencé à cette époque m ce
que nous appelions la restriction au
minimum nos dossiers
cela veut dire que nous avons détruit
tout ce qui pouvait donner des
informations sur nos agents sur les
sources que nous avions dans les
institutions les plus variés sur
l'étranger se font échouer
le nouveau pouvoir communiste décide de
lâcher du lest c'est à dire d'entrouvrir
la frontière avec la rfa
le 9 novembre à 18h30 dans une
conférence de presse retransmise en
direct à la télévision
gunter schabowski membre du politburo
annonce une étonnante nouvelle
les voyages où vivent vers l'étranger
être autorisés sans présentation de
justificatifs institut voyage ou liens
de famille les autorisations seront
délivrées sans retard y compris c'est la
durée permanentes elles peuvent se faire
à tout poste frontière
un journaliste pose une question quand
cette décision entre tel en vigueur et
là il se passe une chose incroyable
schabowski consulte ses notes et répond
immédiatement c'est ça immédiatement
ce mois ce simple mot va faire basculer
l'histoire
stupeur et incrédulité étonnement les
journalistes se précipitent ils ne
savent que penser
et télévisions et les radios
occidentales ont exploité ce lapsus dans
tous les journaux d'information qui ont
suivi la conférence de presse
il était en réalité prévu que le
lendemain on ouvrirait la frontière
seulement aux gens munis de papiers
sur lesquels il y aurais tu un tampon
lapsus ou pas
les allemands de l'est n'en attendait
pas tant ils sont des milliers à se
présenter aussitôt au point de passage
vers l'ouest la stasi et les vopos n'ont
pas reçu d'instruction
la barrière de bornholmerstrasse e
s'ouvre la première
il est un peu plus de 23 heures
vers minuit j'ai été réveillé par
l'officier de service
il m'a dit qu'un télégramme avaient été
envoyés en urgence au chef du
renseignement à moscou sur ce qui venait
de se passer
le lendemain ça a été la tempête toute
la journée on nous a appelés de moscou
sur les lignes téléphoniques secrets si
on nous demandait sans cesse ce qui se
passait dans la ville
les services secrets n'ont joué aucun
rôle dans ces événements qui ont précédé
la chute du mur vas y dis la falda ce
qui s'est passé le 9 novembre au soir et
le résultat de cette conférence de
presse de schabowski
une marée humaine investi le mur
symbole de la séparation du monde en
deux blocs il tombe après plus de 28
années d'existence
la guerre sans relâche que se sont
livrés les services secrets se termine
par arrêt cardiaque du bloc soviétique
sans volume et même sa
burqa est entré et m'a dit mais la télé
plus haut ça y était les gens passaient
d'allemagne de l'est à berlin ouest qui
tout ce que je pouvais faire c'était
regarder si
c'est comme une caméra dans un grand
magasin elle marche en permanence et
s'il se passe quelque chose alors elle
est certainement mieux informé que
n'importe
grippaux on a vu plus tard comment se
fait-il que la cia n'ai rien su et bien
peut-on savoir quand la foudre va
frapper ajoute qu'on était à varsovie
quand ça s'est passé il était à une
soirée quand le mur est tombé et moi je
t'ai ici si quelqu'un avait pu savoir
qui est
qui aurait pu savoir d'avant ce que
cette nuit le mur de berlin allait
s'ouvrir
personnes
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
m